I designed Megan to protect Katie from
feeling lonely
she will recognize you as her primary
user and when you do that you're going
to pair with her
crazy it's insane right so we have this
movie Megan and I'm so thrilled to talk
to you all about the formation of the
character of the AI doll but my first
question is very basic when you all were
on set if you were what was your first
interaction and your first impression
when you saw the doll in in flesh or
plastic I guess well first it was a test
right we actually saw before the movie
even started shooting what was your
response when you first when we saw the
early test I was like holy smoke this
thing actually looks very real
you know like they did this incredible
animatronic head of well I don't want to
talk too much about it but this
animatronic head of Megan you know like
the way she moved her eyes is the skin
texture it was pretty incredible uh it
was actually very exciting at the same
time because you know up until then you
know it's really just ideas on paper
right on script form and you're not
quite sure if you're going to be able to
pull it off so when that test came along
and it proved to us that we can actually
make this work it took the whole movie
in our heads to a whole different level
yeah it was exciting we were trying to
ride a line so that when you're watching
the movie you're you forget for a minute
that it's Ai and then you're reminded
harshly that it's Ai and the I think the
movie doesn't work unless you can really
suspend disbelief like that and I think
that the way that Megan was created
really does that and it's a sort of the
perfect evolution of the the scary doll
sort of thing that we've seen in movies
before where you can even go back to the
Twilight Zone episode when there's a
ventriloquist dummy yeah and then you
have fats from Magic yes and then we
have obviously Chucky and Annabelle but
this is more more like it's the
artificial intelligence it's the
technology that's making it scary as
opposed to something that's paranormal
so how do you make that shift and still
like maintain the scariness of it yeah
we I mean we knew that we were playing
in a very established sub-genre but that
doesn't mean that you know we can't go
in there and move things about right try
new things and definitely change out the
engine if the engine in the past for
previous scary doll movies have been
Supernatural of Supernatural origin you
know it just makes sense to kind of do
something a bit different and given the
state of the world and how technology is
so prevalent in our everyday life it
just felt naturally that it wanted to go
in that direction and uh and listen you
know
the AI world can be pretty terrifying
you know it can be incredibly useful for
us as well but uh but it's also pretty
scary and uh and of course this being a
horror film we're leading much of this
we're leading to the scary side
well yeah I mean it's almost scarier in
a way than anything Supernatural because
I feel like we have so many Supernatural
based horror movies that I know how to
get myself out of that I know I can call
a priest I can call an exorcist but with
this if I lose my password I'm screwed
so I don't know how to how to infiltrate
and I an AI That's gonna miss and I
think that's a really fun sandbox for
y'all to play because it's such new
technology yeah I think that's good
there's nowhere to hide from AI I think
that's kind of good that'll be the
tagline for the sequel there's nowhere
to hide from AI
yeah no it is I mean we've become so
reliant on technology that uh that the
idea that these things that we create to
help us you know help us live our daily
lives could actually turn against us you
know it's like the classic cautionary
tales that you've seen in past movies in
in books and stuff like that and uh and
it you know it's been a while since
there's been a movie like that so it's
kind of cool to kind of go back into it
and especially now you know given how
how much more
um AI has become such a big thing in
recent recent times right that uh that
that I think this movie has become
somewhat very relevant and we think of
you know at least uh probably all of us
when we were kids we didn't have the say
aye and we didn't have streaming stuff
so you go to the video store so when I
watch a movie I still put myself back in
Blockbuster and I'm like well what
section does this movie fit into I'm
clearly stocking it in the horror
section but there's a lot of dark comedy
in here too and those are the two movie
types that you love going to the theater
to see opening weekend right because you
get that instant reaction is that why
comedy and horror works so well together
I mean I think partially what you're
saying I think the reason it works well
is comedy makes horror more effective
because if you laugh in a movie you
relax and your defenses are down you're
you kind of forget for a second that
you're going to be scared any minute and
then when the scare comes it's much more
effective because you're not ready for
it and then you laugh after the scare
because everybody else
yeah yeah I mean that that's common
thing you know like when you beat up the
tension if you do it successfully you
beat up the tension and then you pay it
off and the audiences end up you know
they scream they cover their eyes and
they want to release that tension by
laughing at something right and uh and
just the nature of of Megan you know
like the story of Megan it leans into
something that can be very Darkly
humorous and uh to not shy away from
that was important for us okay so one of
the humorous moments that again is still
scary but it's also you have to kind of
chuckle is Megan's dance moves so I feel
like the dance moves I don't know if
y'all had anything to do with the
inspiration for that I've never been to
a wedding with you gentlemen I don't
know what it looks like but it feels
like it's a mix of like real good
movements but then also like the drunk
person at the wedding reception
I don't know where those dance moves
originally half from half from our actor
have from the director half from half
from God I don't know I'm not sure I
mean that's really it I mean you know
the great thing about what Gerard can do
so well is you know is he can kind of
walk that fine line of you know creating
scary suspenseful moments but then kind
of know when to have fun and do the
funny bits right and uh and you know
making dancing you know they in that
during that little moment before she
turns dark just adds to her personality
adds to the sassiness but uh but there's
so much about what she does that that
makes her who she is and and that is
also a part of um the evolution of the
story right she's learning things from
this little girl and this little ghost
teaching her have a sing and dance and
she's just applying that to uh her
murderous ways yeah yeah the singing as
well I had the uh the pleasure of
talking with the incredible Allison
Williams who's fantastic in this movie
and asked her what pop song could Megan
sing that would ruin that song for her
she said a Barbie world which is a
pretty good answer I was thinking like
maybe Megan could Rick Roll us but do
you all have a song that that Megan
would just completely ruin for you if
you heard that creepy doll sing it
I don't know if it will ruin it for me I
actually will probably like it even more
so I'm not the right person to ask this
if you want to give me the creepy
version I'm all for it yeah exactly well
I did want to briefly ask you all about
uh you know there there's buzz in the
industry right now there could be a
production company merging and uh with
one another is there is there things for
horror fans that get excited about
YouTube working more together and maybe
even some some franchises crossing over
potentially in the future yeah well
we're still we're working towards uh
concluding an agreement where we would
be where would be two two merge
companies which would be uh which would
be really exciting I think what it would
be in store for horror fans if that
happens is more great original horror
movies and then and then obviously we'd
be working with ip2 but trying to keep
those movies also feeling kind of fresh
and new and different I think that's one
of the things the two companies do well
on their own and would do even better
together we talked about Annabelle
briefly but there's been this internet
beef apparently Chucky is getting in his
feelings about this new doll on the
Block so how do we feel about Chucky
sort of needling Megan online and then
how does Megan respond to that I mean
you these are two of arguably along with
Annabelle the most famous scary puppets
in the history of movies so how do we
settle this I would love to see the
Avengers of creepy puppet dolls them
coming together I either um a versus
version or them teaming together to take
on a more powerful entity I want to see
that version it be the King Kong and
Godzilla where they fight initially
because they don't know each other and
then they can team up and who's going to
stop not one not two but three scary kid
styles all together that would be good
what is it about the that inanimate you
know it's a it's a child's play thing
and so you two are our masters of horror
why are we so scared by that why does
that lend itself so easily to the horror
genre well just because Child's Play
anything toy related is supposed to be
innocent right and so the idea that you
come along and you corrupt this innocent
object that was designed for you know if
a happy playful things suddenly now
takes on a malevolent life that is where
the sort of um that sort of Disconnect
come from and that's what doing things
like that is kind of what makes you know
make stuff like that work on a
psychological level you know you don't
expect your doll that you love that you
grew up with your teddy bear whatever to
get up and try to strangle you in the
middle of the night uh but the idea that
it could do that is what's terrifying
and I think when you're young
that's the objects those are the objects
that you animate when you're young those
are the objects that you imagine are
coming to life all the time that you're
a kid so even as an adult when they
actually do come delayed it's like
you're and they're bad it's your worst
fear come true so in your terms is Toy
Story one of the scariest franchises in
the history it really is
movies in that in the scary the scary
puppet doll genre
but they're cute they're very cute
they're they're very cute until they're
not right that's the thing about scary
movies like this so uh finally I guess I
know 2023 is going to be a huge year for
both of y'all individually then maybe
together as well what can audiences
expect from your crop of movies that
you're producing you're writing that
you're working on next year after Megan
we have uh we have uh Exorcist and we
have another couple a couple of movies
that that haven't been announced yet
that hopefully will come out next year
and uh I think audiences can expect
um to be scared in new and different
ways that's what I hope to always
deliver in in our movies yeah
hey I'm sorry let's just talk about it
hey hey let me go whoa hey what's going
on hey Katie hello what are you doing
stop it Katie calm down let her go
Megan turn off are you sure
so I love Megan as like the next sort of
iconic horror movie villain who is the
horror movie villain for you in your
formative years that you're like oh
that's the that's the one to stay away
from that's just a good question I'm the
girl from The Ring 100 Samara oh my God
I to this day like shower drains or
televisions like all of it it's just
like phones scary I like can't she's
just in there deeply and I watched it a
lot when it came out and too much Wells
I just keep coming back to images from
it that are scary Cliffs even just her
like combing her hair literally a girl
and no matter how many times I saw a
scary movie which was a lot and I saw
the parodies of it it doesn't matter
like it's just haunting to see someone
with long dark hair combing their hair
looking in a mirror it's just scary
there's a little connective tissue
between someone like Samara and Megan
where at first they're just like they
look like oh you're just like an
innocent little girl kid but now
something has changed so something has
changed the first time you were
introduced to Megan in in the plastic
like on set yeah what was that moment
like well I don't want to spoil like how
Megan comes to be because I think it's
better to enjoy it with some amount of
the illusion but
um
uncanny Unforgettable when I first met
her she was
um in Repose and that was deeply
chilling she was just alone in like a
corner of a Sound Stage people were
doing camera tests off on one side and
she was next to like a table with props
and I just walked in and she was just
standing there and I was like
I'm not I'm not gonna survive this movie
because this is so terrifying
um Temptation I wonder because like I'm
curious if you were to pair with Megan
right yeah what sort of personality
traits do you think Megan would would
pick up from you how would Megan change
in my dreams she just becomes like the
like most on it executive assistant
where she knows what food I'm about to
order before I order it and it shows up
like those are the ways I would use her
um I mean the temperature that could she
administer covid test like that would be
super useful if she just looks at you
and she's like I have bad news and
you're like what she's like there was
just a coven particle that passed in
front of your face and you got it that
would be amazing okay so she's kind of
like the Alfred to your Batman
perfectly put please switch seats with
me that is exactly the way I would put
it but I mean you kind of got to put
some superhero oomph into this role too
so a little bit how do what is your
advice if in the future we all have
these AI Companions and you gotta tussle
with one of them how do you think in
there just program Oh you mean once the
once everything's failed guardrails are
off yeah
go for the CPU
okay that's all I'll say go for the CPU
okay and my final question this might be
the most important question that you may
have all day okay I'm ready so Megan
does enjoy singing and Performing she
does yes what pop song could Megan sing
that would completely freak you out I
don't know oh my God I wish I had like
an instant I mean Barbie girl would be
really haunting to go Peak Millennial
with it yeah like a stand up of another
doll would just be sort of chilling okay
so Megan maybe not a singer dancer for
you but definitely like the new
celebrity bodyguard
yeah that sounds great it sounds great
honestly a bodyguard that looks like
that is sort of subverting expectations
the way I love
don't stop
[ __ ]
what the hell was that
[Music]
you should probably run
congratulations on the movie um I wanted
to ask you about Megan the doll and the
first time you got to sort of be on set
and see her in the flesh or plastic as
it were I mean it's it's funny because
you there's so much that goes into
making her and you're really nervous
about whether or not she's she's going
to come to life in the way you want her
to that
um you know it was it was helpful to
just have the the cast and crew there
when we all kind of really met Megan for
the first time and you could just tell
instantly by their reaction that we had
something really special like she's
hypnotizing so there was an unveiling of
Megan for everybody to kind of
experience it together well there was
because the people who designed her we
were originally supposed to shoot the
film in Montreal and so the people who
designed her when we moved the filming
because of covert to New Zealand they
had to come to New Zealand and so they
unloaded her off the truck and all those
things and had said pretty her up and
all that so there was a like there was a
big unveiling uh and so and so everyone
gathered around for it and there were
other aspects of Megan there was like
the Megan Barton so we had this Big Show
and Tell of all these things and yeah
it's like you're Wheeling Hannibal
Lecter down for the first time yeah
exactly I know it was like something I'd
have met him too so I was like I guess
you know it's like this thing who's kind
kind of um she's real but she's not real
and you know it's it's a cool hybrid
though in the movie as as far as the
premise goes with the artificial
intelligence but also just for you
having the Practical doll to work with
but then there's also a lot of CG I
imagine so so how many times was Megan
actually like acting in a scene versus
the CGI and post-production it was it's
hard to say the ratio
um I we had all the faculties we needed
to make Megan on hand at all times and
sometimes it was uh it was just a
difficult decision of thinking yeah I
remember in pre-production that it was
it was so often like oh we should should
go with this version of Megan or should
we go with this version of Megan and
there was confusion sometimes and you'd
end up on see it and they'd say Oh I
thought we were making doing it with
this version it's like oh no oh okay
we'll just go with this version and see
how it goes and so yeah it was very
complicated I'm curious for you just in
your formative years when you're coming
into this love of film when did you
realize that that horror and there's a
lot of comedy in this movie so when did
you realize that it was a perfect
marriage sometimes in a film to get
equal doses of horror and comedy well my
first film housebound was like a f it
was a funny idea that lent itself to
being a horror movie hence you know why
it's a horror movie but
um I was a horror fan but I don't think
I was equipped at that time to make one
and I learned the hard way just how
difficult it is to create tension and
how cinematography is so important what
the camera is doing but uh having
watched that and sat in a room full of
people that are audibly reacting to
everything was just intoxicating and so
the idea of doing that again it was just
yeah it was a no-brainer and that's
what's the the greatest thing I could
say about doing a comedy horror is
you're well aware of how the film's
going yeah the audience will let you
know right away I imagine there's always
going to be a response to the dance
moves and so I'm curious how you got
those dance moves for Megan because it's
half like super talent and then it's
also just half like drunk person in a
way so how do you come up with with the
moves well I have to give credit to a
local dance teacher who
um uh one of the the the performer of
that in the film it was her dance
teacher it was a real it was a real
Family Affair and you know they figured
it out themselves I gave them a brief
and said this is what I want and this is
the timing I want this is a song I want
and and we had like about seven or eight
things and you know lined up but this is
just the first one we got to do because
we were out of time
um but you know it's yeah it's it's it's
yeah it's become I mean it's just it's
it's been fun to see it just embraced
and I guess it's it's easy enough for
people to do and get involved if it was
too tricky I don't know